welcome to another Q&A episode of the
stronger by science podcast the podcast
is currently embroiled in controversy so
we begin today's episode by addressing
the controversy and sharing a brief
announcement about the big mass Black
Friday sale then we get into some
questions today's questions involve
protein powders accommodating resistance
pull-up technique how to tweak your
training program to break through
plateaus and much more to finish off the
episode Greg and I share our
perspectives on the most useful
evidence-based dietary supplements if
you'd like to have your questions
answered on a future episode or if you'd
like to capitalize on the big mass Black
Friday sale you can find the links for
both of those in the episode description
as always thank you for listening and
joy the show
welcome back to another Q&A episode of
the stronger by science podcast this is
your host Eric Trexler today I'm joined
by special temporary guest host named
Greg knuckles thanks for having me thank
you for joining me today now you know
this one time you should be thankful
people who've been following me on
Facebook know that I've been strongly
considering turning down
Eric's offers to continue being the
temporary guest host mainly because he
said some very inflammatory things on
the podcast that are tanking ratings and
really damaging the strength of the
stronger by science brand so do we want
to talk about that yeah I mean there's
no question that's the stronger by
science podcast right now is in crisis
management mode we brought in a
consulting firm that specializes in
crisis management so we're gonna address
all the controversy in a minute now
before we get to the controversy I do
have a quick announcement if you're a
regular listener of the podcast you've
probably heard Greg and I talk about
mass which is the monthly research
review that we put out every single
month with dr. Mike Soros and dr. Eric
Helms every issue contains ten pieces of
content to make sure that you stay on
the cutting edge of the newest research
related to training and nutrition so
whether you're interested in getting
bigger stronger more powerful or leaner
we've got you covered if you've been
waiting for the right time to subscribe
to mass the right time is coming up soon
our big annual Black Friday sale is from
November 25th to December 2nd and not
only are these the lowest prices of the
year but in addition a huge amount of
the proceeds actually go to charity
every year we choose a different charity
and this year the charity is the
American Foundation for Suicide
Prevention so they're gonna receive a
hundred percent of the profit from our
new subscribers from this sale along
with fifty percent of the profit from
current subscribers finally one of the
coolest things about subscribing is that
you actually receive access to the
entire archive of previous issues which
Gregg what is that about like three
years of content now
yeah it should keep you busy for a while
we would need to go back and do full
tallies again because we haven't done
that since the anniversary sale but I
think it's going on 3,000 pages of
content at this point so there is a lot
in there it'll keep you busy for a while
and hopefully you'll learn a thing or
two okay so getting on to the
controversy
we got a scathing extremely negative
review on iTunes I say we but it's
really I got a negative review there was
an episode in August where I might have
said that there are some very very bad
people pushing for marijuana
legalization I I feel like I should just
read this whole comment for context yeah
go ahead
so this was a one star review left on
our iTunes page just as a note if you
like the podcast go rate it if you don't
like the podcast stay as far away from
the ratings as possible but anyway ryan
van d wrote pretty recently title of
this review is co-host should create his
own podcast i think he means the
temporary guest host but we'll let that
slide so he writes august 14th at 18
minutes and 50 seconds into the episode
the main host calls people that legalize
marijuana
quote horrible people hard to respect
any quote unquote scientific advice from
someone in 2019 that holds disparaging
and antiquated views on marijuana the
podcast is only valuable because of the
information provided by the co host and
he should create his own podcast series
alright so let's get a couple things
straight right off the bat that i have
put many many many legal safeguards in
place to make sure that greg will never
ever start his own podcast so that right
off the bat that's a ridiculous premise
now regarding the controversy our
regular listeners might remember that we
opened up the first episode with an
extremely lengthy warning that we tend
to be very sarcastic our regular
listeners might also
remember that we on almost every topic
have a pretty laid-back pretty chill
approach and don't really care what
other people do
they might also remember that I in fact
started that exact segment by quoting
South Park and saying drugs are bad
m'kay which alludes to the numerous ways
over the years in which South Park has
openly mocked those ridiculous in-school
drug prevention programs that make
marijuana seem like the most dangerous
thing in the planet you might use that
information to triangulate the idea that
I was being sarcastic when I said that
only very very bad people would promote
the legalization of marijuana and that
this would deteriorate the moral fabric
of our country and crumble the family
unit so I'd like to make it extremely
clear that I was in fact not being
sarcastic I meant every word of it and I
am doubling down since day one we've
been very clear that the secondary
purpose of this podcast is to spread
good evidence-based fitness information
however the primary purpose of the
podcast has been to support and
cultivate what I would call middle-class
Protestant family values I would call
them traditional wholesome family
centered values that protect the
morality of our country and really the
country of anyone listening so that's
still the primary focus of the podcast I
stand by all of my disparaging and a
scientific comments about marijuana
anything to add Greg if you come on any
of our media trying to push the wacky
tabacky the devil's lettuce thinking
that it's it's cool to roll up fat J's
we're gonna put you in your place
that's not cool it wasn't cool in the
70s it's not cool today and yeah quite
frankly I'm appalled that anyone would
think that we would even possibly be in
favor of that and another thing people
forget is if it was okay then why would
the federal government make it illegal
right you know I mean the federal
government has made two or three
mistakes previously but it's it's
honestly a very small number I think we
can all agree so odds are if there's a
law on the books it's a good law correct
and like America is a Christian nation
and if you have problems with the walls
of America you have a problem with Jesus
I think so and get get that [ __ ] out of
here so hopefully that puts that to bed
I think we have a couple other a couple
other Corrections we need to talk about
while we're on the just the onslaught of
criticism coming toward us yeah so I was
informed that the second Christian Bale
movie where he got super skinny for
other than the fighter is the machinist
and not the mechanic I got several
messages from very angry machinists so
the machinist cohort that listens to the
stronger by science podcast we love you
we respect you I did not mean to slight
you like that so Christian Bale movie
the machinist not the mechanic something
that is actually serious is in a prior
Q&A episode when someone asked about
sleep extension just general strategies
to promote it if you know they've been
trying to go to bed super early and
found it hard to go to sleep and
actually get more sleep than they had
been getting previously one of the
things I recommended was instead of
trying to make a huge change to your
bedtime just moving it forward about an
hour to me that seemed like a reasonably
small change one of my Instagram
followers
I believe her handle is the heart is a
muscle to message me on Instagram she
used to work in a sleep clinic and one
of the things she said that they did for
their patients was if someone was trying
to sleep more instead of moving bedtime
forward by an hour instead just go in
like 15 or at most 30-minute increments
because even an hour can be a pretty big
change in terms of circadian rhythm
stuff so she said the general advice was
solid but instead of trying to go to bed
an hour earlier
just initially start with moving your
bedtime forward about 15 minutes if
you're finding you're having a pretty
easy time falling asleep with that
slightly earlier bedtime then try
another 15 minutes and just don't make
that hour jump all at once all right so
as Greg said I want to reiterate if you
hate the podcast and you just rage
listen to it for two and a half hours a
week every week do not review the
podcast but if you like the podcast a
great way to support it would be to go
and review it positively wherever you
listen to it and share it with 20 or 40
of your closest friends alright moving
on we got some questions this week first
one is for Greg the question is from
it's all you sis
the question is Greg any advice on
easing into a high volume hypertrophy
focused amezo cycle after a powerlifting
meet without losing ones strength gains
yeah absolutely so there's a few pretty
simple strategies you can use so first
thing I'd recommend is if you are like a
pure powerlifting athlete and you're not
you know trying to balance powerlifting
half the year with say bodybuilding the
other half of the year like if you know
you're a power lifter 365 days a year
but you're just entering the offseason
one thing I'd recommend which will do
most of the heavy lifting as far as
helping you retain your strength is just
not going super low intensity in your
hypertrophy cycle so you know I wouldn't
recommend doing much work at least for
your core lifts of say sets of 12 to 15
if most of your training for like
serious powerlifting usage is save reps
or sets of like 1 to 6 reps for your
hypertrophy work you know keep it in
like the 5 to 10 rep range you can grow
just fine doing sets of 5 sets of 8
whatever you don't necessarily need to
do higher higher rep stuff and if you
want to do some of that you know save
that for accessory exercises for squat
bench deadlift and clothes variations
thereof keep the reps relatively low
higher than it
would be an impure strength focus block
but again somewhere between five or ten
reps per set
you're never going super low intensity
that in and of itself will probably be
enough to hold on to the vast majority
of your strength it may drop a little
bit just because you're not peaked and
you may be a little less comfortable and
proficient with like ninety five percent
plus loads but that's gonna do most of
the work for you if you want to do
something beyond that something you
could do is set up your hypertrophy
training with say like a month-long
Mezo cycle that you repeat and say you
know maybe spend three weeks of that
month training in the five to ten rep
range and then every fourth week make it
something a little bit heavier so you
know you maybe do a set of or you do a
week of ten so you do a week of eight
you do a week of sixes or fives and then
you do one week of heavy triples
seventy-five percent of your training is
still in rep ranges that likely promote
more hypertrophy on a per set basis but
you're still touching something pretty
heavy at least once a month
that should help you hold on to a lot of
your strength while still making most of
your training hypertrophy focused and
the last thing you could do and I'd
especially recommend this if you wanted
to do just like a pure hypertrophy block
you know you do you're peaking cycle for
a meet you're like okay I'm done with
heavy stuff kind of worn down by it I
just don't want to go super heavy in the
vast majority of my training let me just
do you know sets of ten to fifteen
something you can do then is just do an
over warm single before you do your
volume work so nothing that's going to
be a grinder nothing that's going to
take you particularly close to failure
but I feel like it's it's almost become
a meme in certain circles at this point
of just doing a single at rpe eight
before you do your volume work but I
think it's popular for a reason that's a
very valid strategy to you know not do
anything particularly challenging but
still put something pretty heavy on your
back
or in your hands it's probably gonna put
you somewhere in the 88 to 92 percent
one rep max range which is pretty heavy
that's gonna help you hold on to those
neural adaptations for lifting heavy
stuff it's not going to be particularly
stressful it shouldn't negatively impact
your subsequent volume work maybe you'll
get a little post activation
potentiation and it could even help you
with your subsequent volume work you
know just add some singles at 8 in and
just add that into a hypertrophy
training block you know you should grow
and still hold on to the vast vast
majority of your top-end strength so
those are the three strategies I'd
recommend you can combine them you can
just choose one of the three or any
combination thereof now I've got a
question about the post competition
period here sure
so we've talked in previous shows about
tapering you know usually people would
take a week maybe two but usually a week
leading into a meet and kind of lower
their workload
do you do anything special the week
after the meet or do you dive right into
this new mesocycle depends how the
athlete feels if they absolutely crushed
it at the meet and they're super super
motivated to jump right back into
training we jump right back into
training if they do super well at the
meet one of the things I've noticed is
like oftentimes if lifters have just a
curvier day on the platform they go nine
for nine and you know maybe they hit
five or seven and a half kilos over
their planned third attempts like
everything just perfectly fell into
place they're often more fatigued
afterwards than if they would have had
kind of a mediocre meet so in a
situation like that if they want to get
straight back in the gym we get straight
back in the gym but just that first week
following the meet everything's a little
bit easier so you know not like an
unloading week but something resembling
a traditional D load so you know
intensity is still there we're not
training in like forty percent like
we'll still go 70 80 percent but
volume is reasonably low nothing
particularly close to failure and then
one week after the meet they should be
pretty much ready to go to get right
back into it if they had a really
awesome meet and they're like hell yeah
that was awesome but that was also a
really grueling training block I want to
take a week off sure they can take a
week off I mean there's 52 weeks in the
year taking one week off after a meet
isn't gonna kill you or if they have
kind of a subpar meet and they're super
motivated to get back in the gym to make
sure that that doesn't happen again
we just dive right back into it and I
find that in a situation like that
they're generally not quite as fatigued
from the meet so we don't have to play
it quite as conservative in the first
week back training makes sense to me all
right so question from JP is there any
benefit to a quote unquote personalized
blend of protein supplement or is it
just an excuse to jack up the price I'm
gonna respond to that question with a
question for Greg are you familiar with
these personalized blends so this person
could be asking two different things
the first and this has been around for a
long time man I'm blanking on the name
of the site but I know it's where
everyone used to buy bulk protein from
back in the day but Dante Trudell site I
remember that yeah where one of the
things that they pushed is you can make
a custom blend and they would kind of
recommend that it be a mix of if you you
know didn't have much of a price budget
you might go like way hydroxylate and my
cellular casein if you were on more of a
budget maybe like a mix of whey
concentrate and milk protein isolate our
milk protein concentrate I mean which
would be mostly casein and so like
theoretically mix of fast and slow
digesting proteins maybe a little bit
better for you so that's something
that's been around a long time something
that is a little bit more recent
is like essentially that but they just
kind of ask you like you know do you
have any dietary restrictions are you
lactose intolerant are you planning on
taking the shake before a workout after
work after a workout before bed like
just takes you through five or ten
questions and then spits out what it
says the theoretical best blend of
protein for your goals is so maybe
asking about that so same deal but
they're just taking the decision out of
your hands pretty much make it for you
yeah yeah I figured that was the case I
always just I wanted to check to see if
there's some new stuff I wasn't aware of
but that's pretty much what I thought so
protein generally speaking is pretty
simple
I don't think it makes a lot of sense to
over complicate it and get too bogged
down in the details now there are
reasons that you might need to buy what
I would call a special protein I think
for the majority of people the kind of
default protein is some kind of way or
way mixture it's cheap it mixes well
it's you find it everywhere it gets the
job done but there are some specialized
types of proteins that might make sense
in certain scenarios so if you're vegan
obviously you're not going to want a
whey protein and so you can find some
kind of plant source protein and if
that's the route you want to go I'm sure
you could buy some from our good friend
James Cameron that's one part of the the
game-changers documentary that we didn't
talk about in our review completely
unrelated that product the producer of
that documentary made alike I think a
hundred million dollar donation into pea
protein wasn't it no no no an investment
yeah I was gonna say it wasn't it wasn't
a donation yeah it's not a charity no no
no no no I'm pretty sure he dumped like
over a hundred million dollars into a
pea protein company totally unrelated
had absolutely nothing to do with the
game-changers content at all but yeah if
you're vegan plant source proteins
totally makes sense
SOI pee rice I think they make now
there's all sorts of different
plant-based proteins ooh the one that is
hot these days is mushroom protein or
like fungus really so I think it's
pronounced corn but it may just be corn
I think it's like qu Oh are in I don't
think this study is published yet but I
saw and kind of like sport nutrition
Twitter people sharing around a picture
taken from a conference where they
looked at the acute effects of on muscle
protein synthesis of I want to say it
was corn versus way it may have been
corn versus like beef protein or
something but basically corn versus some
high-quality animal protein source and
either muscle protein synthesis was the
same or slightly higher with the corn so
anyway that's kind of exciting that's
interesting yeah I wish they would have
used the term it isn't already a totally
different thing that you could feasibly
try to make a protein out of you know
yeah yeah I also heard that people were
trying to push cricket protein a lot
back a couple years ago I heard about
people making a lot of buzz about
cricket derived protein so we'll see if
that catches on obviously not for vegans
but interesting nonetheless
but yeah so so if you're vegan it
totally makes sense to go with a
plant-based protein obviously and
there's all sorts of proteins out there
generally speaking generally you're
gonna need a slightly higher protein
dose with any of the plant-based sources
can to get the similar muscle protein
synthesis you would expect from a dose
of way generally speaking now if you're
super calorie restricted that might be
another reason why you get very specific
about your protein choice and so there
are all sorts of way isolate products
out there that are very very low in
carbohydrate and fat so that might be a
reason that you would say I don't want
just any old way blend I want to make
sure it's a very low calorie whey
isolate
based product if you have digestion
issues when you consume protein perhaps
a hydrolyzed form might be nice for you
what they do is they hydrolyze some of
those peptide bonds already generally
speaking the rate of digestion is a
little bit quicker and maybe that'll
help certainly judge digestion issues
could also relate to it's possible that
dairy just doesn't sit well with you and
you might go for an on bit a non dairy
protein product like one of the
plant-based ones or beef or egg or
whatever happens to be a little bit more
suitable for your GI system now a lot of
people try to push really hard for a lot
of people like to advocate that you have
to get very specific about the rate of
digestion I think for the vast majority
of people that's probably not the case
generally speaking a typical whey
protein is going to perform
exceptionally well when it comes to
stimulating muscle protein synthesis
what you want to do when you take a
protein powder is get a nice big bolus
of amino acids get a big spike in the
blood stream and from then on out you're
pretty much good for the next few hours
and then later you're gonna want to do
another one sometimes people will say
you know all you got to go with this
hydrolyzed version because it'll get in
the bloodstream
five minutes quicker or whatever the
heck they say it doesn't seem to be a
big deal the reason you would go for a
hydrolyzed protein would be for some
reason I need to have this at a time
where a whole protein just bothers my
stomach maybe you're taking it during a
workout maybe right after workout you
struggle to get whole proteins in that's
fine
casein a lot of people push it before
bedtime I think it's fine but I think
when you make a comparison of way versus
casein just completely head-on
I think the way tends to outperform
casein just a little bit in terms of
muscle protein synthesis I wouldn't
expect it to be a meaningful difference
but I think it is a slight difference I
mean or just like throw some Metamucil
in your way shake to slow down digestion
a little bit yeah yeah that's that's an
alternate approach and also poop a
little better yes for sure but generally
speaking you really don't need to
micromanage the
rate of absorption too much I mean if
you were getting 2 if you took an
approach where you like micro dosed and
took like very small amounts of casein
and just like intentionally tried to
screw yourself over by never having you
know a big spike in blood amino acids
theoretically that could be a problem
but why are you doing that to yourself
don't do that generally speaking if
you're getting a decent protein product
and you're taking it in bolus form and
each dose itself is sufficient to cause
you know to elicit a nice muscle protein
synthesis response you should be fine
you shouldn't need to micromanage it too
much at that point it just becomes
preferences of how many calories do you
have to work with do you have any
ethical constraints on what you're
willing to buy and if you have any food
allergies sensitivities or GI issues
that you're trying to work around should
be pretty simple okay we got another
question for Gregg here it is from
Virgil on a previous podcast you talked
a little bit about sticking with a
powerlifting program that works and then
you know now and then tweaking it to
make sure you're getting the most out of
it
and in that conversation you talked
about sticking with basically the same
base program for a pretty extended
period of time
now the question here is how exactly do
you go about tweaking it so when you
find this base program that works and
you're thinking about implementing some
tweaks before you completely hop to a
new program how do you go about doing
that tweaking process yeah so so first
things first
I wouldn't recommend making tweaks until
you do actually plateau on the program I
think a lot of people do get a little
bit greedy and are chasing the ghost of
optimal which I mean the thing about an
optimal training program is like one it
would only be optimal for a short period
of time your body adapts dynamically and
whatever is optimal training for you
like you know if we think of optimal as
like a point quantity whatever is
optimal for you right now
won't be perfectly optimal a month from
now and certainly not three months from
now so you know even if you hit it you
wouldn't hit it for long
and then - once you reach theoretical
theoretically optimal training you would
have no idea that you've gotten there
there would be no way to know that that
was the ideal thing for you so I think a
lot of people do get greedy chasing that
Unicorn which they probably won't catch
and want to know that they had caught if
they actually did catch it so my first
piece of advice is just progress is a
beautiful thing if you're still making
progress on a program don't mess with it
however when you do actually Plateau the
first question you need to ask yourself
is just generally do I need to make this
program harder or easier and this could
differ lift to lift
so maybe the training program that
you're currently on is of appropriate
difficulty for your squat your squat
still going up benchpress the program
has become too easy
you're not making progress but your
upper body feels fresh all the time you
know
no no indications that you're having
issues recovering from your bench
training but you're not getting stronger
so you know you probably need to do
something to make your bench work more
challenging deadlift on the other hand
is you know plateaued but your lower
back is sore all the time you just feel
generally fatigued from the waist down
maybe you're developing some aches and
pains that weren't there before
that might tell you that your deadlift
training needs to get a little bit
easier so for the rest of this question
or the rest of this answer just keep
that in mind when I talk about modifying
a program I'm mostly talking about
modifying training for a particular lift
which you know could be you may need to
make similar modifications for all of
your lifts at the same time or it may
just be making tweaks kind of one lifts
at a time but anyway with that being
said you need to start by deciding
whether your training generally needs to
get harder or easier well how do you do
that I alluded to it before if you are
making progress don't mess with anything
if you're not making progress but you
generally feel fresh all the time you
don't really have any leading indicators
of overreaching or overtraining
then you know you're you've probably
just adapted to the training that you're
currently doing and you need to do
something to make your training more
challenging disrupt homeostasis a little
bit more spur on some more gains if on
the other hand you're not making
progress but you maybe do have some
signs of overreaching you're sore you're
rundown you're fatigued all the time
maybe you're developing some aches and
pains that weren't there before that
might be telling you that your training
is a little bit too too challenging for
that particular lift and you need to
pull back a little bit it could also be
issues with stuff going on outside the
gym like maybe you're stressed out maybe
your sleep isn't good maybe your
nutrition isn't on point but I've given
the full version of this flow chart
before hopefully if you've listened to
the podcast before all of this is
sounding familiar let's say you're
taking care of business outside the gym
and you are feeling run down and you're
you've plateaued on a particular lift
you probably need to do something to
make training a little bit easier so
let's start with that second scenario
first you've reached a plateau you need
to do something to make your training
still challenging but a little bit
easier just because the stress you're
putting on yourself seems to be in
excess of whatever you can recover from
what I would generally recommend in that
case is just take a look at whatever
training variable seems to run you down
the most and just do a little bit less
of that so that's going to vary person
to person and probably lift to lift as
well for some people if they're
frequently going pretty heavy like let's
say 85 90 % of their max are above they
get run down super quick they find that
really stressful they find that it takes
them longer to recover from heavy
workouts if that's the case then you
know probably pull back on the intensity
a little bit maybe add a couple more
reps per set but drop the intensities
program-wide by 5% or something like
that theoretically that should still be
quite a bit of stimulus but stimulus
that you have a little bit easier time
recovering from if on the other hand
you're more sensitive to volume
and especially like moderate-intensity
type stuff so you know you can do
triples til the cows come home but as
soon as you start doing sets of eight
and especially a bunch of sets of eight
you just feel super sore and worn down
and start fatiguing really quickly then
what I would do is you know maybe snip a
set off per workout for that lift maybe
bump the intensities up a little bit and
do a little bit less of the higher
volume moderate intensity work if that's
what you tend to find more fatigue so
just in general try to keep try to keep
set volume where it was first and just
shift intensity in whatever direction
you find less stressful so you know
either shift everything up by about 5%
drop reps accordingly or shift
everything down by about 5% and drop
reps accordingly that's the first thing
I'd recommend if you find that that
doesn't really do the trick for you this
I think is is sacrilege in the modern
powerlifting world but it may be worth
considering dropping frequency as well
especially as lifters get stronger and
stronger often times they find that the
they just have a really hard time
recovering from the same frequency that
they used to be able to do no problem so
you know maybe you're used to squatting
three times a week but you find man I
really need to take two or three solid
rest days between each squat session
then you know you could probably
consolidate what you're currently doing
in two days of squatting per week maybe
drop total volume by a little bit 1020
percent like drop off one to three
weekly sets but consolidating it in to
squat days per week to give you a little
bit more time to recover a lot of people
especially as they get stronger find
that to be a viable strategy they just
find they can't maintain the intensity
quite as well anymore so if you do need
to make something a little bit easier
those are the strategies I would go for
if it's the opposite scenario
and you know you feel fresh you don't
have any aches and pains you don't
really have any indicators of
overreaching or overtraining but you're
not making progress you probably need to
do something to make your training a
little bit harder and I feel like we may
have talked about this on a previous
podcast or it may be something that I
talked about on a on another podcast
where I was a guest but if I haven't
been guest on this one too FairPoint be
yeah
so if you do need to make your training
more difficult something I found or
something I've just generally observed
is that some people respond better just
generally to lower weekly set volumes
but closer proximity to failure and then
some people do a little bit better you
know maybe leaving a couple more reps in
the tank but just doing a [ __ ] ton of
sets and it's I mean I don't know of any
indicators that would kind of tip me off
to which one of those two would work
better for particularly particular
individuals but those would be what I
would test so what I probably start with
trying is keeping set volume the same or
maybe even dropping a set per workout
but pushing closer to failure so if you
generally leave two reps left in the
tank drop it to one rep left in the tank
or you know if you generally leave three
reps in the tank drop it to one or two
in the tank and I found that for some
people you know just generally pushing
closer to failure per set making each
set more stressful is really the ticket
to gains for them and on the other hand
you know maybe even making each set
slightly easier but just doing more of
them that helps a lot of people as well
and I find that people tend to fall into
one of those two archetypes and you just
kind of have to troubleshoot it and see
so you know I would try one of those
approaches if it goes well great if it
goes poorly and you know maybe you swing
all the way to the other side of the
pendulum if you stay plateaued but now
instead of feeling fresh all the time
you feel worn down all the time you'd
say well this was an unsuccessful test
let's move in the other direction so you
know if you start buying getting closer
to failure and that doesn't work for you
add a couple more sets leave two or
three more reps left in the tank give
that a shot one of those two will
probably work for you
so yeah that would be my general advice
and if you do wind up increasing set
volume I think it's kind of up to you
whether that should go towards your main
lifts or accessories I think that's
mostly a matter of personal preference
and then the last variable that I that I
would mess with as with making training
less stressful is fiddling with
frequency in general I would say use
frequency mostly as a tool to increase
volume if you need to so if you find
that you're one of the people who
responds best to high set volumes a
little bit further away from failure
eventually you reach a point where
workouts can just be unmanageably long
like you you know you don't want to do
probably eight or ten sets of squats in
a session so then you can just split
that work up into more sessions so I
wouldn't necessarily fiddle with
frequency first if you do find that you
need to do more training because your
current training isn't quite stressful
enough to cause gains I would I would
increase frequency when you find that
practically it just makes sense to
increase frequency to get in the set
volume that you need to on a weekly
basis now a lot of a lot of times you
hear people talk about hopping from
program to program as an objectively
negative thing like people admit it like
it's a flaw I have I'm a program hopper
do you think there's any value to
embracing that early in your lifting
career like as long as you're giving it
like a good eight weeks to just see how
it goes or maybe 16 weeks do you think
there's value in just jumping between
some very different set programs at when
you're new to lifting figuring out which
approaches seem to work for you and then
refining from there yeah I I wouldn't
necessarily do that when you're super
new to lifting just because like you've
respond more dynamically when you're a
new lifter so you know if something
works for you five years into your
training career something pretty similar
is probably what's gonna work for you
six years into your training career but
what works best for you three months
into your training career and nine
months into your training career could
be very different things so you could
try that approach you know and maybe if
you're someone that gets bored easily
that makes your first year of training
more fun and engaging and obviously
there's inherent value in that but I
don't know that the information you
glean from that would be all that useful
and reliable down the line I do
absolutely think there's time to just
cut bait and run from a program so I
would say I would say that you know you
run the program as written or maybe with
just like a couple of tweaks on the
front and if you generally know what you
like and respond well to and you're like
okay I'm gonna make a couple of tweaks
to this program and give it a shot you
know run that till it stops working and
then maybe make three rounds of tweaks
to it and then I would say like once
you've done a particular style of
training for long enough that you've
stalled on it even with tweaks for like
the third or fourth time and you know
maybe you make another round of tweaks
and you just really don't get anything
out of it
I do think there's value and just kind
of cut in bait and doing something very
very different you know if nothing else
it might make training a little bit less
boring if you're you know maybe stalled
because you're just bored with your
current program you've been doing the
same style of training for two years and
you just need something fresh maybe you
get more gains just from being more
engaged in the process because it's
something new and fresh and exciting I'm
not completely sold on the idea that
novelty is
an independent variable that improves
training results but I don't think that
it's completely implausible that that is
a thing either so you know maybe you
just make some more gains from novelty
and then you know maybe like I think I
think it's easy to think of training
programs as just kind of like a
combination of inputs that all kind of
scale linearly with each other but
different programs just have different
bones to them such that like sometimes
if you tried to make a hybrid program of
two generally decent programs you've
lined up with something that's just a
complete [ __ ] disaster so examples of
that would be like
Shaco style training and Westside both
of them have produced a lot of very good
lifters but if you tried to make a shake
oh Westside hybrid it would probably be
a complete [ __ ] show just because like
the bones of those two programs are
fundamentally different so like I don't
think so
you know let's say you start on a Shaco
style program it's working generally
well for you you make a few tweaks new
plateau you make a few tweaks you
plateau I don't think you would ever and
let's say in this universe the
theoretical optimal style of training
for you is Westside style training I
don't think you would ever effectively
tweak your way from Shaco style training
to Westside style training like I don't
think you would reasonably bridge that
gap and just kind of organically make
your way from one to the other so I
think eventually when you do just
finally stall hard on a particular style
of training it is worth just trying
something completely different because
there may be something else out there
that is much better for you that you
would never get to just by tweaking the
same program for your entire training
career so yeah I do think there's some
value to that but like I said the core
of my philosophy here is that progress
is a beautiful thing and so so don't
you know burn down the ship when it's
still generally sailing in the right
direction but once it runs aground
burn the [ __ ] down build a new one
start again from scratch okay question
fortrex from Logan Logan asks what is
your opinion on mass gainers I asked
because I travel frequently for work
which makes bulking very difficult
without eating a lot of junk
currently I eat relatively quote/unquote
clean for all meals and consume a mass
gainer to hit my calorie goal so Logan's
consuming mass gainers doing that
instead of eating a bunch of junk food
what is your opinion on mass gainers in
general and in Logan's specific
situation does that seem like a pretty
decent compromise yeah so mass gainers I
generally have a negative view of them
but that doesn't mean that they're
necessarily a problem so if you want to
go that route and use a masking or
that's totally fine I just think that
they have I think they have a reputation
that's way better than they deserve so I
used to use mass gainers when I was in
like high school I really needed to gain
weight for wrestling and so I would eat
a full breakfast and then throughout my
first class of the day drinking a mass
gainer which is like a thousand calories
and then during my second class I've
always been the way I am in terms of
just genuinely not caring about food if
you know my lasagna recipe you know all
about this but when I was in high school
I would just bring plain pieces of bread
to class and just eat slices of like
Wonder bread if during class but yeah
I've never really cared it's always just
like get the calories in so if you're
just trying to get the calories and mass
gainers are fine but the reason I think
that they're they get treated they get
more respect than they deserve is we're
basically looking when we look at a
weight gainer we're looking at a whey
protein shake with just a really boring
ass carbohydrate like maltodextrin just
all over the place so they're pretty
much giving you here's some whey protein
and we got to get the calories from
somewhere so we're gonna put a generally
boring carb source in there just for the
sake of energy
and so my my approach to trying to gain
weight is why not just get a good way
protein and then just eat something
really cool with it so like uh you know
you mentioned in the in the question
you're trying to bulk without eating a
lot of junk
I guess the disconnect between me and
mass gainers is I don't see them as non
junk I see it as a whey protein shake
with a ton of just boring calories mixed
in but nothing particularly beneficial
yeah and just so we're on the same page
here maltodextrin is for all intents and
purposes sugar right it's just a
relatively short chain of d-glucose
molecules all linked together those are
super easy bonds to break I think that I
think a lot of times people are too
quick to label things as essentially
sugar but maltodextrin is essentially
sugar like it's it's literally just
glucose probably within ten minutes of
hitting your stomach right yes so if
someone were to tell me like I'm gonna
switch from having a mass gainer to
having whey protein and two candy bars
is that have I made a step down like am
I now eating junk where I used to be
eating good food I would say you're
pretty much in the same place we're
talking about getting in whey protein
with some amount of calories and frankly
whether you're getting your calories
from a candy bar a pop-tart or just a
huge serving of maltodextrin I don't
really see those as being particularly
different and so you know I've had I've
taught a bunch of beginning weight
training classes Gregg you have as well
a lot of times you'll get somebody who's
like I'm desperate to gain weight what
do I do and I'm like get enough protein
throughout the day weighs a convenient
way to do that and just like eat a candy
bar drink a mountain Dew
it's just whatever it takes if you're
really struggling to get in like some
solid food just go for whatever is easy
to get down and so I think for me the
thing
that's interesting about weight gainers
is people view them as being better than
junk food and I think it's just because
supplements companies put their stamp of
approval on it and that's something you
see for instance when people get really
negative about artificial sweeteners
you'll see them talk a lot about diet
sodas but they won't worry about the
fact like how come every fitness
supplement I consume is sweet but
doesn't have sugar in it it's like well
because there's just artificial
sweeteners everywhere in it right but
like you'll see people demonize Diet
Coke but I very rarely see the the
situation where people highlight the
amount of artificial sweeteners in their
amino acid product or their protein
product or like their pre-workout or
their pre-workout yeah so I think
there's something about the fact that it
comes from a fitness oriented company
that makes you feel like ok they want to
put anything out if it were junk food
but in reality I just I don't see a huge
difference when I look at a weight
gainer versus a scoop of whey protein
and like 6 pop-tarts to me they're
pretty equivalent but again that doesn't
mean that it's like inherently stupid to
have a mass gainer if that's convenient
for you and you like the flavor the mass
gainer and it works for you that's
totally fine you're not losing anything
but I think a lot of people are
restricting their food choices
unnecessarily where they would be
totally fine if they just got a pretty
generic whey protein product and just
ate whatever food they really really
love to eat which is probably gonna make
them enjoy that process a lot more yeah
I mean for Logan's situations
specifically if he's traveling a lot it
kind of depends whether it's a airport
travel or not because if it is like you
have issues bringing pretty much any
kind of food with any water content
through security but you know if it's
just like you're on the road a lot like
whey shakes and bananas or fine you know
you can leave bananas and a hot car all
day I have done it many times they're
dirt cheap there's probably going to be
some sort of grow
restore essentially anywhere you would
travel to it's cheap and quick to pick
up some bananas that would probably be a
better option just away shake and
bananas or really any kind of food you
like and if you're worried about it
staying fresh just like take a small
cooler with you put like one or two
little ice packs in the bottom fill it
up with [ __ ] apples or oranges or
whatever you want that would probably be
about as easy as a mass gainer more
nutritious and probably tastier too yeah
and I kind of painted a picture of
comparing a mass gainer to just junk
food
the best-case scenario would be you
you're also getting some nutrients and
while you're doing this right so like
you said a banana some fruit whatever
whatever you want to take in if you
could get in some some some source of
calories that also brings nutrients with
it that's great
usually when people use these it's on
top of a base diet that has plenty of
fruits and vegetables and it's like I
just need the calories and and when
people need the calories and they're
struggling because their appetite is
just totally shot and they're like how
do I get calories and without feeling
gross of course weight camp weight
weight gainers are a way to do that it's
totally fine but I always like to make
sure people realize like if you don't
want the weight gainer you could just
have way and like literally your
favorite food ok question for Greg from
t'me Trias B the question is after
seeing the other Eric that is Eric Helms
doing some pull-ups I thought to myself
he doesn't get his chin over the bar so
the question is from a strength or
hypertrophy standpoint is it important
when doing pull-ups to get the chin over
the bar yeah so t'me Trias you just
about got yourself in in some hot water
mentioning the other Eric in the
hallowed halls of the stronger by
science podcast you almost got a warning
we don't like to speak of him around
here however you redeemed yourself by
calling out his just utter [ __ ]
cheater ass fake pull-ups but no so
actual serious answer to the question
um I think it is fine to not necessarily
do a full range of motion on pull-ups
specifically not getting your chin all
the way over the bar or especially not
getting your chest to bar which some
people are sticklers about the reason
why I would say that is pull-ups have a
really weird strength curve so when you
think about an exercise like say bench
press bench press is generally hardest
near the middle to bottom of the range
of motion and once you can get the bar
past that you can lock out pretty easily
some people fail at lockout but that's
that's a pretty uncommon thing and if
you fail at lockout I think more often
than not it's an issue with scapular
positioning more so than just like sheer
strength but that's another discussion
for another day but anyway and that's
how most of the lifts we do are
somewhere between the beginning of the
lift and the lock out of the lift there
is a hard section or somewhere between
the start of the lift in the middle of
the lift I mean there's a hard section
once you get past that you're good to go
that applies to pinch it applies to
squat it applies to overhead press even
applies to something like skull crushers
so that is the general strength curve
you're dealing with and so if you cheat
range of motion in exercises like that
by not going down all the way you're
missing out a on the most challenging
part of the lift and be the most
challenging part of the lift tends to
occur when the muscles are any
reasonably stretched position and that's
important because there's some evidence
that a longer ranges of motion are good
for hypertrophy but B that is important
mostly because putting muscles under
load in a stretched position seems to
maybe cause more hypertrophy than just
muscle tension itself so you know for
example doing full reps versus just
flexing your muscles really really hard
you know if you're completely untrained
just flexing may help you build a little
muscle but it's not gonna do much for
you if you have any meaningful degree of
training experience however by just
flexing you can put a ton of tension on
the muscles but it's probably not going
to be near maximal tension in a stretch
position so you know most lifts are
limited by what you can lift through the
shortest or through a particular range
of motion but that particular range of
motion is near that very important
stretch position in the pull-up on the
other hand it's very much the opposite
so the hardest part of the lift for for
the vast majority of people doesn't
occur when your muscles are in or near a
stretch position but rather when they're
in or near a fully contracted or almost
fully contracted position and the thing
is like that just doesn't seem to be
quite as important mechanistically for
hypertrophy so I don't think I don't
think it's that crucial that you
necessarily go full range of motion on
pull-ups meaning getting your chin way
over the bar every time I do think it's
important to go down all the way because
that's putting you in that stretch
position for your lats but I don't
necessarily think it's important to go
all the way up and in fact it is
theoretically may be counterproductive
just because you tend to be so much
weaker there at the very top of the lift
that if you're if you're stopping a set
when you can no longer get all the way
up on a pull-up you probably haven't
really challenged the rest of the range
of motion all that much yet it's still
really easy at the bottom in the stretch
position it's still really easy through
the mid-range which is probably where
you're maybe creating the most muscular
tension it's just really hard at the top
and so if you stop when that is limiting
you you may be stopping the set before
you're actually fully challenging
yourself through the more productive
parts of that range of motion so I think
you could you could do one of two things
with that either you could
stick with like a standardized range of
motion that maybe isn't chin over bar or
maybe like chin right at bar but not
like chest tube are certainly so more
like a moderate range of motion and then
stop when that range of motion starts
failing you so you know maybe you pull
up until your nose is level with the bar
when you can no longer get your nose
level with the bar you call the set
there that's probably going to be a
range of motion where like you're not
going to be quite as limited in the very
very top part of the lift as you would
be if you were going chin over bar every
time something else you could do which I
think would probably be the best option
of any of them is to do pull-ups where
you start with a load where for the
first few reps of the set you can go
through a full range of motion so you
know chin over bar maybe even
substantially over the bar and you know
if you're doing weighted pull-ups start
like start each set or do each that with
a weight where for the first maybe three
to five reps you can go chin over bar
full range of motion and then just be
fine with letting your range of motion
get smaller and smaller and smaller
until eventually you reach a point where
it probably isn't productive anymore so
you know if you can't even get your
forehead to bar height you're probably
fatigued enough at that point that
really you're not accomplishing that
much anymore but you know I don't think
you need to have the same range of
motion for all of your reps you know go
until the weakest part of the range of
motion fatigues and you can't get chin
over bar anymore then keep going until
like a slightly stronger part of the
range of motion fatigues and you can't
get really any of your face over the bar
anymore and then just call the set there
I think that's probably gonna get you
the best of both worlds
if you do get anything particularly
beneficial from kind of getting to that
squeezed fully contracted position
you're still getting a few reps per set
where you are going all the way up but
you're not letting that limit how hard
you can stimulate your muscles through
the rest of the range of motion so
that's what I would probably recommend
but just in general to answer your
question about Helms's pull-ups you know
as long as he's not going through like a
third of the range of motion like you
know if he's going eyes to bar like nose
to bar or something like that that's
probably perfectly fine and you know I
got I got a lot of flack for saying that
people pushing marijuana are bad people
but they aren't as bad as helm so I was
a bad guy he's gonna cheat his range of
motion and he's just not trustworthy
whether it's with his range of motion or
other things could not agree more all
right question for Eric from Dan Han are
there any merits to this study the study
here is linked if not how can mere
mortals make the conclusion that this
study was subpar or not accurate in its
conclusions so what is the study he's
referring to and what conclusions was it
trying to draw
all right good question so the the study
that was linked there is called
intermittent versus daily calorie
restriction which diet regimen is more
effective for weight loss and this was a
review article and it was by a
researcher who's done a lot of work in
the area of intermittent fasting but
it's important to note that this review
article was written in 2011 and so we've
learned a lot about intermittent fasting
in the time since 2011 so you know good
research doesn't expire but for certain
topics you know we'll see a review that
comes out early in the development of
that body of literature and then we'll
have more data that come out in
subsequent years and it refines our
understanding so I'm not really
interested in like picking apart any
particular aspect of where this review
might have fallen short or what might
have been missed in it because I mean
we're talking about a review paper
that's nearly a decade old and you know
much of the literature that's really
informed our our viewpoint of this
strategy has come out in the last decade
or so so rather than saying that a
particular review paper was right or
wrong I'd be more interested in just
looking at the more current totality of
the evidence in that area so this review
paper was about
imminent calorie restriction and this
authors done a lot of work specifically
as it pertains to different approaches
to intermittent fasting we've talked
about this a little bit before so I
don't want to spend too much time on it
but when we talk about intermittent
fasting in the research literature we're
usually talking about something
different than what you're thinking in
the fitness industry so in the research
literature there's usually three main
approaches to intermittent fasting there
is alternate day fasting where
approximately every other day you do a
fasting period where you either eat
nothing or I think usually the cutoff is
less than 25% of of your normal daily
caloric intake
there's also 5:2 fasting with two
consecutive fasts so basically five days
of eating and of normal eating and then
two days of really low caloric intakes
like I said usually about 25% or less of
your normal daily intake and then
there's a 5:2 approach that uses
non-consecutive fasting periods so just
two days out of the week interspersed
within the week of substantially lowered
intakes usually that's what we're
talking about with intermittent fasting
and the research literature so far
there's been in the last few years
there's been I think three meta-analyses
that have come out with slightly
different approaches to you know which
literature they wish to include which
outcomes they wish to look at but
generally speaking those three metas
paint a pretty solid picture for us in
terms of interpretation an intermittent
fasting research currently would suggest
that it is a viable but not
unequivocally superior strategy so if
you want to use these types of
approaches obviously you know the
research would indicate that they can be
used effectively just as effectively as
a more typical dieting approach where
you just lower your calories every day
but generally speaking we don't see a
huge superiority comparing one approach
to the other so at that point it really
just becomes what's your preference you
know what would you find to be a more
tolerable dieting approach you can go
with it you'll probably be alright now
most of that I think pretty much all of
the of the data coming from that
the intermittent fasting approach is in
untrained people so if I was working
with somebody who is training pretty
hard pretty frequently I certainly
wouldn't have them do one of these
fasting days on a training day and I'd
be a little bit more cautious about
using this type of approach where we're
spending an entire day of fasting I
think what we know about the temporal
aspects of protein feedings would
suggest that that probably wouldn't be
your default option I'm not saying it
could never be used but it that would be
probably the approach you take when
you're you're dealing with some pretty
unique circumstances or you're really
working down your list of available
dietary tools and you're like okay plan
a didn't work Plan B didn't work now
we're to Plan C do we think this might
be a viable approach so yeah I certainly
wouldn't have a fasting day on a day
that you are trying to Train and
generally speaking if you're somebody
and you're your strength or your muscle
gains are particularly important to you
I think there might be better strategies
to use before you fall back on a day
that includes or on a dietary approach
that includes entire days of fasting now
when we talk about intermittent fasting
in the fitness industry we're usually
talking about time restricted feeding
and so that's you know we're not taking
entire days off of eating but rather
we're just condensing the the time
window each day in which we eat so some
people have like a four-hour window
between noon and 4:00 p.m. where they
eat all their calories for the day
probably the most common approach
currently is an eight-hour window from
like noon to 8:00 approximately but you
can put that window basically anywhere
you want there is some evidence that
putting it earlier in the day might be
slightly better because it aligns a
little bit better with some some
circadian biology but realistically is
probably a pretty modest difference
depending on what time of day you put it
but in any case there is some research
using those types of protocols with the
time restricted feeding specifically
looking at resistance training people
that are training during the study those
studies would indicate that just like
with with intermittent fasting the
approach seems to be just
good but no better than a more typical
dietary approach so it seems like again
if it's something that helps you with
your adherence or it fits your schedule
better it's certainly a viable option
you could use and it really comes down
to fitting the preference of the dieter
some people really like the simplicity
of having a narrow time time window to
eat in and they really like the fact
that there seems to be some benefit in
terms of increasing satiety less desire
to eat on a diet when you're able to
restrict that time window a little bit
so there are some people that it makes a
lot of sense to say listen before noon
we're just not going to think about food
we're gonna have our feeding window
we're gonna be able to eat large meals
and then we're gonna stop eating for the
day and that the simplicity I think is
really helpful from a psychological
perspective for a lot of people so it's
no better or worse than a typical
feeding strategy based on the evidence
we have available which is not a ton
there's a few well-done studies in
resistance trained people and grant
Tinsley has been involved with with
several of those studies her say several
but there's like a couple of them but
but grant was involved on the two main
ones that I think about in this area the
one area where I would express a little
bit of caution or at least reservation
so usually when we see these studies
people are they are obviously adapting
to a new training program and they're
generally not in a huge deficit or a
huge surplus for calories the one thing
I wonder about knowing what we know
about the timing of protein feedings is
if we did a study with slightly
different circumstances where the whole
point of the study was to maximize the
rate of muscle growth so if we were like
leaning hard into a bulk or on the
inverse if we put people in a position
where they were at really increased
likelihood of losing muscle mass so
really lean people that are still trying
to lose fat or people that have a pretty
big caloric deficit day to day I wonder
if those types of designs might reveal a
very modest a very
light advantage of having more even
protein feedings throughout the day
totally speculative totally based on
mechanisms rather than observations so
who knows if it would actually pan out
that way but I wonder if when you get
into specialized circumstances where
we're either trying to absolutely
maximize the rate of muscle gain or
trying to reduce muscle loss in
relatively extreme conditions I do
wonder there's a little idea in the back
of my mind that makes me question
whether or not it would still be
equivalent but it's totally speculative
at this point based on the research you
can't throw out time restrictive feeding
as a subpar strategy I just wonder about
those very unique circumstances about
whether it would still be able to keep
up with a more typical feeding strategy
where you have multiple sufficient
protein bolus throughout the day in the
at the end of the day though when we're
talking about an eight hour feeding
window that's basically a normal day
eating right I mean it's basically
skipping breakfast like eight hours is a
long time to eat yeah I mean I I
remember I remember when like the lean
gain style of intermittent fasting was
first getting popular and people were
acting like it was this extreme kind of
thing it's super mainstream now but back
in whenever that was like 2009 people
were like oh my god this is crazy I
remember looking at it as someone who
wasn't like you know super deep in the
bodybuilding forums at the time thinking
like why are people making a big deal
about this it's literally just skipping
breakfast like millions of people do
that every day yeah I mean you think
like I'm gonna have breakfast I like
9:00 in the morning maybe have lunch
around noon have dinner at 5:00 that's
an eight hour feeding window yeah I mean
that that's not a super atypical thing
so the research would indicate with an
eight hour feeding window from from the
observations we have it seems to do just
as well in terms of both fat mass and
lean mass in conjunction with resistance
training as I mentioned you know I don't
know if it will still perform equally
well in those unique circumstances I
wonder how much you really sacrifice
when you shorten it from an eight-hour
window to a four
because I do think a four hour feeding
window compared to a typical day of
eating that's a fairly different change
in pattern I think but for now what we
know is that alternate day fasting and
time restricting time restricted feeding
in the applications that we've actually
observed with these types of
interventions it seems to do just as
well as know better so some people look
at these approaches and have hope that
there's some kind of magic bullet that's
gonna really give them the edge
unfortunately that doesn't seem to be
the case for most people however the
encouraging thing is it might be
something that either helps you with
your dietary adherence or fits your
schedule better and the evidence would
indicate that they are totally viable
options okay question from Jason Kohler
Greg what's your take on accommodating
resistance for absolute strength it
seems like the most logical way to go
it sure does seem like it doesn't it so
the basic idea behind accommodating
resistance and if you're not familiar
with that term that's just you know
adding band tension or chain weight or
doing reverse band squat bench deadlift
really any lifts so the the idea behind
it is that it helps match up the force
curve of the exercise with your natural
strength curve so talked about the kind
of funky strength curve of pull-ups a
little bit earlier where you know you're
a little bit stronger at the bottom of
the lift and through the mid range and
weaker at the top the vast majority of
exercises it is the exact opposite
so you're weaker at the start of the
lift you're stronger at the top of the
lift just use chains as an easy example
you can match up that strength curve a
little bit better so you know let's say
you can produce 300 pounds of force at
your weakest point in the benchpress
two inches off your chest and you can
produce 400 pounds of force right at
lockout then you know theoretically if
you go for a 1 rep max with 300 pounds
you're really really challenging a
pretty small range of motion and then
the rest of the lift is relatively easy
you can most people are going to be able
to lock that out without much of a
problem once they get past their
sticking point with chains on the other
hand you can maybe go 285 pounds of bar
weight and a hundred pounds of chain and
then you know right at that sticking
point maybe you're you're still dealing
with 300 pounds of resistance but now
you're dealing with 385 at lockout when
your theoretical maximum is 400 so it's
challenging you through that entire
range of motion instead of just
primarily through the range of motion
where your weakest so it matches up the
strength curves better should
theoretically build more strength
through the entire range of motion maybe
that's going to be good for developing
absolute strength as Jason Kohler asks
so it's nice in theory in practice the
research doesn't really bear it out so
there was a 2015 meta-analysis by Soria
Gila archaea and colleagues and that
meta-analysis basically pulled together
the research they had at the time I
think there were maybe 10 12 studies
give or take decent body of literature
but not huge and the the conclusions of
that meta-analysis were that yeah
accommodating resistance doesn't make a
night-and-day difference when compared
to just lifting straight weight but it
does lead to slightly larger strength
gains I think they looked at squat and
bench press independently because those
were the two lifts that had been tested
on the most and for both of them you
know seem to make a small but possibly
meaningful difference unfortunately
earlier this year another group of
researchers was poking around because
they were planning on doing some
accommodating resistance research they
wanted to see what else was out there
they pulled up the meta-analysis they
you know opened up the individual
studies to see what what had been
previously done and what the results
were and they found out that
unfortunately the the folks who did that
meta-analysis you know through no fault
of their own like no no funny business
going on they just made a human mistake
and miscoded their studies
and when they reran the analysis the
correct way
turns out no effect you know and not one
of those like P equals point oh six
almost effect type things we're talking
no effect whatsoever so that's the state
of the literature I think there have
been maybe two more accommodating
resistance study since 2015 and they
were also pretty lackluster so at least
when you look at the research that's out
there it doesn't really seem like
accommodating resistance really beats
straight weight so you know let's ask
ourselves why that might be and I think
it is I think the explanation is
contained in something we've already
talked about on this podcast which is
that when you fail a rep you don't fail
because you were too weak through the
entire range of motion you fail because
you were too weak through your very
weakest point in the range of motion so
you know it's cool that bench press with
chains can make lockout more challenging
to make the whole lift more challenging
through the entire range of motion but
if when you load the bar up with
straight weight well the if the
make-or-break point is there at the
bottom of the lift which is already your
weakest point is accommodating
resistance then actually doing anything
for you like ultimately that is the
range of motion that's going to be
challenged for every set you ever do if
it's a moderate load and you take it
close to failure that's where you're
gonna start straining and start grinding
if you you know work up to a 1 rep max
that's the range of motion where force
output through that range of motion is
going to determine whether you get the
rep or not so that is the crucial range
of motion that is the make-or-break
point for if you're gonna get the lift
or not and it is challenged to the same
degree with straight weight or with
accommodating resistance or if anything
if you're too ambitious with
accommodating resistance it could even
be counterproductive like let's say your
quarter squad strength is 200 pounds
over your full squat strength but you do
squats with 300 pounds of band tension
then at that point you're going
be challenging yourself at the top of
the lift before you're actually
challenging yourself near the bottom of
the lift where were you're actually
weakest and we're like the make-or-break
point in that range of motion is so they
don't do that in the research they
generally use pretty moderate to
conservative accommodating resistance
but on a practical basis it could even
become counterproductive if you get too
aggressive with it so anyway I think
that is the reason why we see in the
research it doesn't really seem to do
much practically I think I mean
practically like raw lifters at least
kind of gave up on accommodating
resistance for the most part close to a
decade ago and by and large if you look
at average performance of just like day
to day lifters it seems to be basically
the same as it was ten years ago so it
doesn't really seem like they lost
anything on the top end of the sport you
know the best handful of people in the
world are getting better and better
records keep falling so they don't
really seem to be missing it and it just
doesn't seem to be that popular anymore
and the sport doesn't seem to be the
weaker for it so I think that's why I
think that so here's what I will say if
you view strength not as your one rep
max squat or your one rep max bench but
more like the area under the force
position curve for like the maximum
force you could produce at all ranges of
motion throughout the entire lift
I think accommodating resistance would
probably be better so if theoretically
you were to run a study where you had
two groups of people squat to full Eagle
powerlifting depth one of them training
with straight weight one of them
training with accommodating resistance
and before and after the study you
tested both full squat one rep max and
quarter squat one rep max I would feel
really really good predicting that the
two groups would have similar increases
in full squat one rep max but the
accommodating resistance group would
have a larger increase in
quarter squat 1 rep max I very much
think that that's what would happen
that's not going to show up on a
powerlifting platform but if you do care
about being stronger through those
ranges of motion that aren't really
tested in powerlifting
I do think accommodating resistance
would probably help you out so you know
in kind of a philosophical sense and
maybe helping you build more strength
but that extra strength may not show up
on your actual powerlifting total one
thing I will say about accommodating
resistance though is even though I don't
know that it's all that useful at least
in raw powerlifting I one think it can
absolutely be useful in equipped
powerlifting you can more closely mimic
the strength curve of gear without
necessarily having to put on gear for
every session I think that's why it got
so popular at Westside in the first
place
so that's an application for it another
application for it is in say like a team
sport setting where you're interested in
strength which are also interested in
power and explosiveness one of the
drawbacks of just traditional barbell
exercises is they have to decelerate
before you reach lockout so you know
with a bench press you don't either
throw yourself up off the bench or throw
the bar out of your hands with a squat
you know you don't want to jump at the
end of every rep probably unless you're
doing light jump squats so you're gonna
decelerate before you reach lock out
with accommodating resistance you can
purposefully push harder through a
larger percentage of the range of motion
instead of having to purposefully
decelerate before lockout so there is
some evidence suggesting that in terms
of like kind of explosive performance
accommodating resistance gives you
better results so so I mean like that
makes intuitive sense especially if
you're doing band work like you can't
you can't move slowly with bands on the
bar they'll [ __ ] bury you so like I
think there there are applications for
training with bands and chains
I do think like I said in a
philosophical sense they may help you
build more strength through the entire
rain
emotion but not necessarily in the part
that limits your performance so it may
not show up on the powerlifting platform
and oh I almost forgot one last thing
that I think training with bands and
chains and I'm thinking especially
chains and reverse bands here another
time when I think they can be really
really useful is if you have a range of
motion dependent like pain or limitation
that's like range of motion dependent
and load dependent so you know let's say
you have the range of motion to squat to
depth but if you're squatting to depth
with more than 315 your back hates you
or your hips hate you or something like
that but you want to keep training
through that range of motion you don't
want to lose it but you don't want to
load it heavy enough that you reactivate
whatever issue you have going on
something you could do to still get
somewhat challenging training and is
maybe you could do squats with I don't
know 255 275 and pretty heavy chains or
you know load 400 pounds on the bar and
heavy enough reverse bands that you're
only feeling 275 in the hole that would
let you train through that range of
motion below the loading threshold that
causes issues so you can still train
through the range of motion in lifts
that pretty closely resemble what you
will be doing once you're back to full
health and full performance while
limiting loading on the problematic part
of the range of motion if that occurs
near the bottom of the range of motion
so that's that's another time that they
can be super super clutch like if you're
training around hip issues or like
shoulder PEC issues in the bench so yeah
kind of a rambling answer but I
definitely think that there there are
good applications for accommodating
resistance I just don't necessarily know
that on average it's going to give you
that big of a boost in one rep max
powerlifting performance with straight
weight so my evidence-based take on
chains is that they happen to be very
badass so back in the day when I worked
with some high school wrestling and
football athletes
I can tell you one thing if we put
chains on the bar it was gonna get crazy
I was going to get 100% effort on every
single rep like it they just look cool
no pressure I mean it and that is kind
of the wild card here
I mean band bands or whatever but like
chains are definitely super cool and
anyone who says otherwise is completely
full of [ __ ] I agree
so I think we got time for one more
question and this one I think makes
sense for both of us to chime in on so
the question is from Gregg's medicine
cabinet that's that's the name they
provided at various points you guys have
talked about creatine magnesium and
snorting algae memes and nightshades
aside and it has a comment here that I
guess
ashwagandha is a Himalayan yak shaving
forum meme I have no idea what any of
those words mean but I know what they
all mean individually but when you put
them together it loses all concept for
me yeah apparently ashwagandha is both a
meme and a nightshade according to this
user the nature of the question is which
supplements don't suck so I'm gonna
start with the non-controversial ones
and we'll let the conversation evolved
from there so creatine is awesome if you
want to be strong if you want to be
muscular creatine is pretty great there
was a recent meta-analysis that we
covered in Mass about creatine and fat
loss indicating that it might help with
fat loss I'm pretty unconvinced by the
data suggesting that creatine might
meaningfully boost fat loss maybe
there's just the slightest just razor
thin effect and that's okay like we'll
take it but you don't take creatine for
the fat loss you take creatine for the
power the strength the muscle gains
interesting stuff coming out about
creatine potentially favorably affecting
bone and the brain I think a lot of
people aren't aware how important
creatine is for the brain like I mean if
you have a genetic defect as it pertains
to brain creatine levels it's
catastrophic
oh and if you're a vegetarian or
I know we've touched on this before in a
prior episode but it was probably three
or four months ago if you're a
vegetarian or vegan like I would
recommend creatine to just about anyone
but I would a million times more
recommend creatine to vegetarians or
vegans like virtually all of the dietary
creatine you're gonna get in is gonna
come from meat consumption and so if you
don't have meat in your diet you're not
going to be ingesting virtually any
creatine in day to day life and so in
the studies that look at performance and
omnivores vs. vegans vegetarians with
and without creatine supplementation the
boost in performance are larger for
vegetarians and vegans and in studies
that look at like mental performance you
give creatine to young healthy omnivores
it generally doesn't affect mental
performance it may in the elderly but
that's that's another topic but in like
young otherwise healthy vegetarians and
vegans creatine supplementation seems to
improve mental performance and mood as
well so yeah I mean creatine is great
for everyone but especially if you're a
vegetarian or vegan find yourself a good
vegetarian or vegan creatine supplement
and use it it's going to be doubly
beneficial for you yeah definitely
the other one that's pretty
non-controversial is protein you don't
need to supplement with protein but you
definitely want to make sure you have
plenty in your diet whether that's
coming from food or from supplements and
when it comes to the the protein
supplements as we've talked about there
are many many many options and all seem
to do a pretty good job as long as
you're dosing them effectively to me
those are the kind of two top tier
supplements that no one's really gonna
fight you on too much but now we get
into the second tier specifically as it
pertains to form performance my second
tier supplements for performance
purposes are caffeine beta alanine
citrulline malate and sodium bicarbonate
the reason they're second tier is
because there was there their effects on
performance are not quite as consistent
in the literature and not quite as large
when you compare them to something like
creatine there are plenty of studies
indicating benefits for each of those
four supplements they each have some
downsides or at least some some types of
exercise where they don't do a lot but
generally speaking if you're taking one
of those four for performance reasons
you you could at least substantiate that
claim with some really solid evidence so
caffeine especially for endurance
performance is pretty reliable caffeine
is pretty solid but there's plenty of
evidence suggesting it facilitates
lifting performance as well
citrulline malate it's a mixed bag it's
it the first few studies looked very
promising the last few that have come
out have looked less promising and so
now I think the citrulline malate
research is really at a crossroads are
we going to start replicating a lot of
those early findings or are we going to
find that the research starts turning
the other way but in any case right now
the totality of the evidence would
indicate that there is a small positive
effect particularly when it comes to
things like repetitions to fatigue you
know strength endurance type outcomes
now beta alanine and sodium bicarbonate
those are more applicable to performance
that involves a high degree of acidosis
so things that are really pushing your
anaerobic energy systems the kind of
classic way to think about it is if
you're doing a 400 800 1200 meter sprint
those are like right in the sweet spot
for anytime you're you're generating all
of that lactate all of that all those
protons trying to buffer some of that
acidity that's where these supplements
really shine if you're a power lifter
and you're doing sets of three you're
probably not going to get a huge benefit
from these two especially if you have
ample rest between sets but but still
there are some certain types of programs
where they might have a place now
outside of that there's really nothing I
recommend for performance outside of
extremely unique circumstances okay but
there are a few other supplements that I
have bought in the past and do use from
time to time the three that come to mind
for me are ashwagandha tyrosine and
theanine aren't aren't you forgetting
one
trend balloon ah yes yes that's we don't
talk about that on the air and copious
amounts of marijuana that I I pretend to
hate just to keep people off of the
trail you know keep people off my scent
but yeah so uh
ashwagandha there are some trials
they're not like the most rigorous
highest-quality trials you've ever seen
but there are some lab based trials
indicating that Oscar got a supplement
can be somewhat helpful when it comes to
anxiety and it is an adaptogen so I
think there's studies looking at
physical exertion as well right
I don't know you take it as well no I I
do I don't have anxiety issues I'm
pretty [ __ ] chill at all that is
completely true
but I feel even chiller when I take a
swig on de and so man I'm just an into
vibe yeah I think there are some studies
not a large enough body of evidence that
I'd call it conclusive but I think there
are some studies looking at responses to
physical stressors as well as
psychological that that indicates some
positive effects slight changes in
cortisol in testosterone levels nothing
to really write home about but the
ashwagandha there's enough there
especially when it comes to some of the
more psychologically oriented outcomes
to say like okay this is enough evidence
to at least at least acknowledge it you
know not not conclusive but and the
other thing I always put a caveat there
anything in the realm of mental health
or anything like that always defer to a
health care practitioner if you think
you have any kind of depressive or
anxiety related symptoms you see a
physician about it right away
you don't say hmm I wonder if there's an
herb I can lean on you gotta get you got
to get professional help for that
tyrosine and theanine tend to pair very
well with caffeine Greg and I are both
just absolutely gripped by our caffeine
addictions no way out of it no light at
the end of that tunnel we are completely
hooked but the cool thing
is tyrosine a lot of times can
potentiate the effects some of the
stimulatory effects of caffeine and
theanine how would you describe what
theanine does with caffeine helps take
the edge off yeah I mean yeah it there's
some evidence that theanine alone people
have promoted it as something to
generally chill you out a little bit and
I know I've talked to some people that
when they take Theni and they're like I
hate it because it makes me sleepy I
think it's kind of easy to conflate like
the general like the way it takes the
edge off and just kind of takes you down
a level and in terms of like your your
amplitude you know what I mean I think a
lot of people they feel that and they're
like I'm tired but but for me I think
theanine is is a really nice especially
if you're taking a big dose of caffeine
you can get the enhanced alertness of
caffeine without feeling like you're
jittery and uncomfortably amped up and
so tyrosine and theanine tend to pair
quite well with caffeine not a lot of
not a ton of lab based research on that
stuff but but but they do tend to pair
fairly well now you put a couple on the
list here well I was actually wondering
if you would like to mention the next
one yeah so so it's it's more in your
wheelhouse I would say correct yeah so
betaine betaine is found in beats that's
where it gets its name but it's also
found in spinach and some seafood and
some whole grains and stuff like that so
beteen betaine is commonly found in the
food supply in various types of foods
and it had there have been some trials
on using it as a supplement and those
human trials are really based off it
seems they're based off B tames use in
the livestock industry for years
especially and I in pigs I believe
they've used it as a food additive in
the the food of livestock to increase
their muscularity and also to reduce
their their excess adiposity and so if
you go all the way back to I mean one of
our first episodes we had dr. Jason
Khalifa on to talk about his betaine
research
and there's not a lot of it there's not
a lot of super relevant data with
betaine but it does find its way into a
lot of pre-workout formulas and there is
some human evidence if you're a mass
subscriber coming up December 1st and
the December issue I reviewed a brand
new meta analysis about betaine and its
effects on fat loss and it does look
like in resistance train people that are
training on a pretty sensible resistance
training program there might be some
modest but measurable fat loss benefits
the effects on performance and lean mass
are not quite as impressive but it might
be a somewhat helpful fat loss aid
definitely need more data we're going
off very few studies on that but but
there's something to it okay so the the
only three that I would add to that list
for more like niche uses well I guess
one isn't an issues it probably applies
to about 25% of humans on the planet but
so one of them is touring so taurine
people believe a lot of weird [ __ ] about
taurine like if if I had a nickel for
every time someone told me that taurine
was extracted from bull semen I probably
have like a buck fifty give or take like
that's that's a reasonably common thing
it's not the the reason it's called
taurine is because it was like first
isolated from cows stomachs but has
nothing to do with bull semen but the
reason I'd put taurine on there is if
you are a bit of a partier or if you
smoke or if you just generally have a
lifestyle that is generate ass I was
going to say generally uncondition to
health but badass yeah that works I
don't know that there's good human
evidence for this yet but there is a
very plausible mechanism and pretty
decent rodent evidence so taurine is one
of the primary antioxidants in your
brain and it is the primary antioxidant
in your testes if you're a male and so
if you drink a lot or if you smoke
cigarettes or just you know generally
live a pretty rough-and-tumble
inflammation promoting lifestyle that
can both decrease brain function and
also decrease testosterone production
and so again in rodent models
supplementing with taurine while also
drinking a lot or I don't know how they
do cigarette studies and mice but they
do somehow I assume they don't roll up
tiny little cigarettes for them but
whatever I think they do
I'd like to imagine they do it'd be cool
yeah anyway so when studies like that in
mice it seems to help preserve just
general brain function and testicular
function so I don't drink nearly as much
as I used to but I did notice that like
back when I did drink a little bit more
when I supplemented with taurine I did
just generally feel more vigor so I
don't know maybe there was something to
that and man so the this was this was a
question highlighted in blue so I
thought Trek's was taking it I didn't do
pre podcast reading I'm gonna throw
something out there that I think is true
if it turns out to be wrong don't
crucify me for it I want to say that
there is also some evidence showing that
in middle-aged males who don't live that
hard drinking smoking lifestyle it can
also increase testosterone levels a
little bit so that's not super relevant
to me but yeah just in general if you
drink if you smoke may not be a bad idea
to take taurine for half the population
for your testes and for everyone for
your brain and potentially liver as well
the next one I had on here was rhodiola
rosea so rhodiola is an adaptogen much
like ashwagandha its benefits seem to be
more related to
like vigor promoting an anti-fatigue
type stuff more so than being anxiety so
there is both pretty good animal and
human research on rhodiola helping to
mitigate mental stress and mental
fatigue so there's there is some
performance literature on rodeo land now
it's a bit of a mixed bag I'm not super
sold on it but as far as mental
performance goes if you are in a good
mental state like if you're well rested
and not stressed out it's probably not
gonna do that much for you but if you're
sleep-deprived if you're under a lot of
stress or if you're like trying to do
something like deal with caffeine
withdrawals or something like that if
you're a crazy person who doesn't want
to use caffeine for some reason
rhodiola seems to improve both like mood
perceptions of energy and vigor and
objectively measured mental performance
in situations where you are dealing with
sleep deprivation or high stress so that
is one that I would recommend for first
situations like that not as good as a
night of sleep but if you can't get a
night of sleep
rhodiola is probably gonna help a little
bit and then the one that I said is
probably relevant for about a quarter of
the global population is vitex agnus
castus or vitex fruit so this one's for
the ladies vitex is super interesting
and it honestly shocks me that I don't
see more people talking about it and
more people taking it so it has a couple
mechanisms of action but one of the
things it does is it's a e to receptor
modulator I'm pretty sure but in terms
of its actual effects if you deal with
really bad premenstrual or mentioning
symptoms or you deal with migraines
associated with
menstrual cycle VTech seems to help
considerably with that
so like decreasing severity of symptoms
by like 30 40 percent if you take it
daily for I think at least two months
can reduce incidents of migraines
associated with premenstrual and
menstrual symptoms again by about forty
fifty percent not a huge huge body of
literature on it but I want to say
there's three or four studies now and
they've all found pretty similar results
in terms of its ability to alleviate
premenstrual and menstrual symptoms so
anyway that is something that if that is
something you deal with
certainly a supplement worth looking
into alright perfect and you know my
general disclaimer is always before you
make any huge change to your
supplementation habits you should check
with a doctor make sure you don't have
any medical conditions or medications
that might interact with that but that's
our rundown of the ones that to us don't
seem to totally suck okay now we started
the episode talking about some of the
just absolutely toxic hate mail coming
our way but we did get some good
feedback from Patrick Barney he said
first noodles are not necessary in
lasagna however lasagna without cottage
cheese is a travesty
so Patrick thank you for your
contribution love having you listening
to the show he also said a very positive
message for Ohio State and a very anti
Michigan statement that I am NOT able to
read on-air hey Patrick would you mind
messaging me your IP address so I can
block you from all of our content no
that's not gonna don't don't message in
Patrick that that is a positively
atrocious lasagna take and I will not I
will not stand by it now another thing
that somebody brought to my attention I
forget who told me this but somebody
messaged me saying I joked about like
how are they gonna start making
carnivore desserts someone is making
carnivore pasta out of shredded chicken
so what's the important thing there is
that shredded chicken is a noodle
substitute based on science and based on
the world around us
which indicates my lasagna puts me back
on the board for the lasagna challenge
and I think puts me over the top for the
win so great to have that if you have
any good feedback like that be sure to
send it all other feedback just hang on
to it okay I think that does it so I
very quickly pulled up a recipe for
zero-carbon meat noodles I have had this
pulled up for five seconds so I haven't
had a chance to fully investigate it yet
but the ingredients I'm seeing for these
meat noodles are chicken breast Old Bay
seasoning eggs and husk perfect what is
husk you know it doesn't sound like
something that goes in food much less
noodles also what's the Old Bay
seasoning for that very much pigeon
holes what you could possibly use these
noodles for like that's a very specific
flavor and it certainly doesn't go in
lasagna it would be fine I think you're
nitpicking cuz you're upset also they're
not like flat lasagna esque sheets like
what I'm seeing now look like kind of
thick linguine noodles you you could
make it work believe me and I did and I
will again I would like to see some sort
of proof of that you ate it you know the
proof all right
that does it for this episode Greg's
upset he's gonna keep rambling about
this and until until the evening so we
better end it while we're ahead thank
you for listening as a reminder we've
got that big Black Friday sale for mass
coming up November 25th it begins as
always thank you for listening and we'll
talk to you next week
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another health care
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it visit
stronger by science com2 check out the
products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you